there's a cause to everything that's
personally what i believe i don't
believe that
i i have like free will i think i have
the illusion of free will but i believe
there's a cause for everything and if
i'm doing something
because of something because of a cause
by definition there's no free will in a
way you know
if there's a cause by definition there's
not how does that make you feel by the
way like the idea that if we just look
uh outside of even just human psychology
and fighting and so on if we look at
like physics if everything is
predetermined
if all of these little molecules
interacting it's already like your story
is already written i mean at the pen
it's it's written but
i would need to know all the data and
it's impossible right
like it's it's i it's kind of weird i
gotta say but i don't
to me i don't see any argument
to counter that idea i i i i can
i don't maybe i'm i'm ignorant but i
haven't
seen nobody and everything that i've
read so far
there's nothing that countered that idea
that that
because in a mechanical world if your
car
broke or you know we don't say oh the
car decided to broke
or a three a tree is fall
there's reason why the tree is falling
we don't say the trees decide to fall
right
so because us human being i think it's
our ego
we decide and i'm no different than
anybody when i make a decision i
decided to do this i choose to do this
but i'm aware that there is causes
that make me do certain things and by
definition i think if there is a cause
there is no free will by definition
right yes but
the thing is just like you said we
understand so little about
human intelligence the human mind and
especially consciousness
that the
this giant mystery this darkness that we
don't understand how
how it how it feels like to be something
to be a conscious being
that because of that we're not able to
really even
reason about free will or not because
there might be some magic that comes
from consciousness
the you know the the consciousness might
be the thing
that makes us different from a car that
breaks down there might be something
uh totally fascinating totally
undiscovered yet that will make us
realize that free will is actually real
and somehow fundamental to the human
experience
so it's sometimes i think
we forget when we talk about free will
and physics and it all seeming to be
predetermined
we forget how little we actually
understand about the world
and i think in that mystery that could
be
totally new ideas that are yet to be
discovered and will make us realize that
it's not just an illusion it is
something that is like
at the core of how the universe works
some people believe that consciousness
is a fundamental property of the
universe like it's a
it's a one of the forces of physics like
consciousness permeates
everything it's in everything like this
table is conscious but it's not
as conscious as us and where this little
peak of consciousness
and if that's true and if we get to
understand that
maybe there's something there's an extra
bonus we get in terms of free will
once you become one of those entities
that are super conscious
so i i tend to be sort of humbled by the
mystery of it
do you believe one day with
with the technology that keep improving
we will
make robot that will be able to
be somehow conscious absolutely
i that's been my dream that's been i
hope i hope to do just that
first of all i believe that all people
are capable
and want to be good to each other and
i think love is uh is a really powerful
thing that connects us and can create
better and better worlds
sort of like create better and better
societies that uh improve both the
technology the quality of life and just
the basics of human experience and i
think
creating ai systems that are conscious
that are human-like
can enable us to be better to each other
like they can it's it's almost like
adding more and more
kindness to the world through the
systems we interact with will inspire us
to be better and better to each other
in terms of them being conscious i think
that is a
an absolute requirement that entities we
interact with
communicate some element of
consciousness
to us like that's how we connect to each
other the reason we you and i connect
is that we believe that each of us are
conscious
and to me what consciousness means is
the ability to hurt
ability to to suffer to uh
to struggle in this world because just
like you said
uh with with without the struggle you
don't have the love
you don't have the pleasure and
ultimately consciousness
is an entity's ability to struggle
to suffer and from that arises the
pleasure
and us together being able to
appreciate sort of uh
appreciate the highs and
experience together at the lows that's
how we form the deep connections
i personally think we can create that in
robots and i i personally believe it's
a lot easier than uh than we think
you